hello everyone and welcome to today's
session three webinar simple steps to
publication quality western blots i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
fisher scientific to learn more visit
thermofisher.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you want during this presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker kelly feather
hennigan a senior product manager at
protein and cell analysis at thermo
fisher scientific
kelly welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining
part three of our webinar series simple
steps to publication quality western
blots
my name is kelly feather hennigan and
i'm a product manager at thermal fisher
scientific supporting our western
blotting products
before becoming a product manager i was
an r d scientist for over 15 years and
during that time
i performed many western blots and
developed many of our current western
blotting products
as you may know in recent years there's
been a growing concern regarding the
reproducibility of qua and quality of
results in western blotting data
submitted for publication
in peer-reviewed journals
in 2014 the journals of science and
nature along with the national institute
of health
organized a meeting with other
publishers journal editors and
scientists to discuss reproducibility
and transparency of published scientific
data
the concerns raised over reproducibility
and quality of western blotting data
submitted to peer review reviewed
journals
led the meeting collaborators to revise
their instructions and recommended best
practices for submitting
non-quantitative and quantitative
western blot data for publication
this webinar series has been broken into
three parts
today i'm presenting part three of the
series which will focus on improving
reproducibility in western blots and
special considerations for obtaining
quantitative western blot results
demonstrating reproducibility of western
bot results has become a focus of some
publication guidelines
anyone who does western blotting will be
very familiar with the workflow depicted
on this slide
western blotting is a very is a very
large labor-intensive workflow with lots
of hands-on steps and areas where
variability can be introduced
with any process that consists of
several time-intensive hands-on steps
like a western blotting workflow
small inconsistencies at any step can
lead to larger issues of blot to block
consistency which could impact the
reproducibility of results
today i'll be focusing on measures that
can decrease the amount of hands-on
activities in the western workflow and
can lead to improved consistency and
reproducibility across blots
in vitrogen's modern western workflow
helps minimize hands-on steps and
reduces time to results compared to the
traditional western workflow
the electrophoresis in steps 1 and 2 can
be simplified using our precast gels and
gel tanks
step 3 the transfer step can be
simplified and time to results reduced
by using our ibot 2 instrument and iblot
2 pre-assembled transfer stacks the time
required for transfer with the iblot 2
system is reduced to 7 minutes or less
and the ibind device shown in step 4 of
this slide can reduce hands-on time by
automating the western blotting amino
acid steps
image capture and results analysis can
be simplified using our ibrite digital
imager
precast gels can be used to greatly
improve reproducibility of western
results
precast gels have many advantages over
manually poured hand cast gels
precast gels have better consistency
because human error has been minimized
and the gels are backed by quality
control standards
they're conveniently ready to use so
they have significant
save significant time by eliminating the
hand casting steps
and our precast gels come in a wide
selection of chemistries and sizes
for our mini gel tank and our sherlock
tandem midi gel tanks both shown there
on the right
we have standard tris glycine and
tryst gels in a broad range of gel
percentages and gradients
tris acetate gels which are especially
great for separating large molecular
weight proteins
tricing gels which are ideal for
separating small molecular weight
proteins
and a variety of other gel chemistries
to meet other needs such as native page
gels and isoelectro focusing gels
our iblot 2 rapid dry transfer device
shown here can be used in combination
with our iblot 2 pre-assembled transfer
stacks
to minimize handling inconsistencies and
transfer steps
and it reduces time to results by
transferring protein from gel to
membrane in seven minutes or less
the iblot 2 system has a built-in power
supply and intuitive software that can
be easily programmed
to successfully transfer protein across
a broad range of molecular weights
from most types of sds page gels
the iblot 2 transfer stacks come ready
to use with either nitrocellulose or
pvdf membrane depending on your
preference and they come in both midi
and mini sizes
the iblot 2 system can transfer too many
gels or one midi gel at a time
and because the transfer stacks are
pre-assembled and contained everything
needed to transfer proteins from gels to
membranes
results are more consistent
consistent and hands-on time is reduced
the iblot2 system provides consistent
transfer across a wide range of gels and
gel chemistries
these data show the rapid transfer of
protein using our ibot2 system with
iblot 2 pre-assembled transfer stacks
and here you can see
efficient transfer of high molecular
weight protein from three different gel
types
and on both nitrocellulose and pvdf
membranes
another option for improving consistency
in western blot transfer is the in
vitrogen power blotter semi dry transfer
system with pre-made transfer stacks
the power bladder system enables rapid
transfer of proteins from a broad
molecular weight range in 10 minutes or
less
when used with our power bladder one
step transfer buffer but it's also
versatile and can be used with
conventional semi-dry transfers with
tobin transfer buffer
power bladder system provides the
flexibility to choose between
nitrocellulose or pvdf membranes in our
ready to use transfer stacks that
contain everything needed to perform
rapid transfers or
we have ready to build transfer stacks
that can be combined with our power
bladder one step transfer buffer for
rapid blotting in 7 to 10 minutes
those ready to use transfer stacks are
ready to build transfer stacks can also
be used with standard token transfer
buffers
the power blotter system can be a higher
throughput option for transfers because
it can be used to transfer up to four
mini
or two midi gels using the power bladder
system with the xl cassette
using pre-made ready-to-use transfer
stacks can increase efficiency and
reproducibility of western blot results
the blots on the right show an example
from a transfer of proteins using one of
our ready-to-use stacks versus a
traditional
build-it-yourself transfer stack
on the bottom membrane you can see an
example of an inconsistent transfer
handling inconsistencies can occur when
building traditional do-it-yourself
transfer stacks
things like
uneven membrane hydration insufficient
removal of methanol or ethanol from pb
pvdf membrane
and stacks drying out while other stacks
are being built can cause splotchiness
and uneven transfer
incorrect setup of stacks with too few
filter paper layers or incorrect
membranes or gel orientation can also
call cause poor transfers and
inconsistencies
these data show the reliable blot to
block transfer performance that can be
achieved by decreasing handling
inconsistencies in this example
twelve individual bolt four to twelve
percent bistrus plus gels were
transferred using the power blotter with
the power bladder select stacks
and each blot was probed for the same
target protein
the transfer results are very consistent
across all 12 transfers demonstrating
how the elimination of handling
inconsistencies will allow you to
provide images to your publishers that
are more representative of all of your
experiments
you can increase consistency and
decrease tedious hands-on steps in your
western blots by using an automated
western blot processing device
such as the in vitrogen ibind flex
western device
the ibind flex allows for automated
immunoprocessing you simply load your
reagents into the reagent reservoir in
the system
and the ibind device utilizes sequential
lateral flow to perform the immunoassay
without electricity
shakers trays or timers
the ibind device provides consistent
robust results
often with less primary antibody than is
required with manual processing methods
the example on the right shows a
fluorescent and chemiluminescent signal
from blots processed either manually or
with the ibind western device
the results are equivalent or better
using the ibind system with 80 percent
less primary antibody than that used in
the manually processed blots
here's another example of results with
the ibind flex system in this comparison
western blot is processed manually or
with the ibind flex western device are
shown
samples containing gst tagged
recombinant proteins were separated on
in vitrogen new page four to twelve
percent gels in mops sds running buffer
and then these were transferred using
the iblot 2 gel transfer device and
stacks
the blots were probed with identical
concentrations of the same pair of
primary and secondary antibodies
the primary antibody was rabbit anti-gst
diluted one to five hundred or eight
microliters in four mils of ibind flux
solution for the ibine system
or 40 microliters in 20 milliliters for
manual tray incubation the secondary
antibody was gold anti-rabbit hrp
diluted one to six hundred
or six point seven microliters and four
mils of diluent for the ibine system
and thirty three point three microliters
and 20 milliliters for the manual tray
incubation
for final detection blots were incubated
for 5 minutes in super signal west dura
extended duration substrate for
visualization on an imaging system these
results show the consistency and
reproducibility of western blot results
using the eyeblind flex system
with less antibody compared to manual
block processing
the ibind device comes with
interchangeable wells that allow you to
process multiple block formats
there are ibind flex well inserts that
will allow you to process one midi size
blot using a single antibody or
condition
there's another that will allow you to
process up to two mini blots at once
using the same or different antibodies
or conditions
or you can process six vertically cut
strips using up to six different
antibodies or conditions
the in vitrogen bandmate automated
western blot processor offers another
option for automating the steps of the
western blotting immunoassay
the western blotting the bandmate
western blot system allows you to load
the instrument with your reagents
select a program and hit go
you can do other activities while the
band mate automatically performs all the
steps of the western blot processing the
band mate can be a higher throughput
option because it allows for processing
of up to four mini blots or two midi
blots at a time using different
antibodies
it has flexible programming that will
allow you to select a default standard
western blot protocol or you can
customize a program based on your
preferences
the bandmate works with your standard
western blotting protocol with no need
to re-optimize conditions or use special
reagents
the bandmate allows you to process each
blot with a different antibody and
collection tubes can be used to recover
your antibodies for reuse in the future
if desired
the automation of the western blot
processing improves consistency in your
western bladder results by precisely
controlling the timing of all of the
processing steps and providing
consistent rocking throughout those
steps
as mentioned in the previous slide
the bandmate processor allows you to
choose from pre-programmed protocols or
you can set up a program to perform your
favorite protocol
the band mate can be programmed to
dispense volumes of wash buffer up to 75
milliliters for many blocks and up to
150 milliliters for midi blots
and each step can be programmed with up
to 10 repetitions per step
the bandmate rocking speed can be
customized between 5 and 40 cycles per
minute and incubation times from 1
minute to 96 hours can be programmed for
plots that require incubation overnight
or for longer periods
and the band mate can be used at room
temperature or the entire system can be
placed in a cold room for long term use
if desired
the bandmate system provides more
consistent and often better results than
manually processed plots
the images on the right show a
comparison of a block processed manually
versus a blot processed using the same
conditions and protocol on the band mate
processor
in this example three target proteins
were fluorescently detected on an
eyebrite imaging system
these results show equal to superior
detection of all three target proteins
on the bandmate versus manual western
processing
the bandmate system improves blot to
block consistency by precisely timing of
the
timing the block
wash and incubation steps of the western
immunoassay
in these results you can see the
consistency of fluorescent detection of
three different antibody targets in
identical western blots processed in
four separate band mate incubation trays
in summary there are a number of steps
you can take to improve reproducibility
and consistency in your western blot
results
choosing precast gels and ready-made
consumables with rapid transfer devices
can reduce hands-on time
handling inconsistencies and it can
reduce your time to results
using more automated tools for western
blot processing steps can also help
reduce hands-on time and improve plot to
block consistency to help you achieve
the best publication quality data
possible
now i will shift focus to special
considerations for quantitative western
blots
as a result of the 2014 meeting held by
the nih and publishers scientific
publishers now have more stringent
guidelines for what they wish to see
from scientists who are publishing
nature wants appropriate reagents
controls and imaging methods with linear
signal ranges to be used for
quantitative comparison
the journal of biological chemistry
wants scientists to record how data were
obtained
whether signal intensity was linear with
antigen loading and how protein loading
was normalized
they also prefer signal intensity to be
normalized to total protein loading
by total protein staining rather than
using housekeeping proteins
but if housekeeping proteins are used
they require evidence that manipulations
do not affect expression
manuscripts with quantitative western
results will likely come under greater
review scrutiny
you can gain a better understanding of
your data using our protein
normalization workflows
in western blotting variability is
usually due to unequal protein sample
concentration
sample loading or variation in the
transfer step
sources of inconsistency can be
monitored with visible or fluorescent
gel and membrane-based labeling methods
followed by quantitation of total lane
protein
or
with exogenous loading controls
sample consistency and health can also
be evaluated using internal housekeeping
protein control such as gap dh
beta tubulin beta beta-actin or
cyclophilin b
in the results on the right you will see
an example of a helolysate expressing
rb1 which was serially diluted separated
and transferred to a nitrocellulose
membrane
the black image on the left was stained
with in vitrogen no stain fluorescent
total protein stain
and the protein of interest was probed
with a primary antibody labeled with
alexa floor 650 die
normalization was performed for total
protein in rb1 and the values were
plotted plotted against protein load
housekeeping proteins are the most
common normalization controls
the table on the right shows a list of
standard housekeeping proteins and their
corresponding molecular weights
it is assumed that housekeeping proteins
are expressed at the same levels across
experiments however recent studies have
shown that expression of housekeeping
proteins can vary
across different cell types and
biological conditions
therefore some scientific publications
and funding agencies now require other
forms of normalization
or validation of normalization controls
to ensure reproducibility and accuracy
of quantitative western blotting results
total protein normalization is the
preferred method because it's not
dependent on a single loading control
protein
the abundance of the target protein is
normalized to the total protein amount
in each lane
this improves the precision down to as
low as 0.1 microgram of total protein
per lane and improves data reliability
and quantitative western blot results
in vitrogen no stain protein labeling
reagent is an excellent choice for total
protein normalization
no stain can be used for labeling
proteins on your protein gel of choice
and it can be used to label proteins on
nitrocellulose or pvdf membranes post
transfer
the no stain reagent offers an easy to
use protocol with mix and add reagents
and can label proteins within 10 minutes
the resulting protein staining with no
stain can be visualized with a range of
imagers
from uv
green or blue led or fluorescent light
sources at a wavelength of 488
nanometers
such as the 488 nanometer excitation
source on the ibrite fl 1500 imaging
system
no stain reagent provides accurate total
protein normalization over a broad
linear range
for detection from 1 to 80 microliters
i'm sorry micrograms of total protein
and has the sensitivity to detect down
to 20 nanograms per band
no stain signal is stable and compatible
with downstream chemiluminescent and
fluorescent antibody detection
no stain reagent yields improved
accuracy for normalization compared to
housekeeping proteins
in this example
helolysate was stained with no stain
reagent and compared with three
different standard housekeeping proteins
beta actin gap dh and alpha tubulin
you can see that the signals from the
housekeeping proteins get saturated with
increasing protein loads of heliolysate
while the signal from the lysate label
with no stain reagent
stays linear with increasing lysate
loads thus making the total protein
normalization a more accurate way to
know to normalize protein
using no stain reagent for total protein
normalization provides excellent
concordance with protein load
here you can see a comparison of
different normalization methods
the percent error for no stain reagent
versus the three standard housekeeping
proteins
from the predicted responses were
computed and compared as shown in the
table
the relative inconsistencies were
normalized to the 10 microgram load
the signal measured would equate to the
predicted signal leading to the percent
error for the 10 microgram loads being
zero
the larger the percent error the farther
the signal is from the
predicted response resulting in reduced
accuracy
the accuracy of the total protein
normalization with no stain reagent was
significantly greater and more
reproducible than the protein
normalization using all three
housekeeping proteins
compared to other in-gel total protein
normalization methods total protein
normalization with no stain labeling
reagent allows you to use your gel of
choice
without the need to change anything and
there's less risk of gel tearing with no
stain reagent because there's no need to
handle fragile gels after
electrophoresis
to expose them to uv light in the
labeling reaction
no stain reagent is also versatile and
can be used to stain proteins on
membranes as well as gels
no stain provides a strong signal due to
binding to plentiful lysing residues and
no stain does not require de-staining
like some other membrane-based total
protein stains
no stain offers flexible detection and
works with uv green or blue led
and eight and 488 nanometer fluorescent
channel imaging so it doesn't require
the ability to read in ir or near ir
channels
you can streamline your total protein
normalization by pairing no stain
reagent with the in vitrogen eyebrite
imaging system
the universal mode of the eyebrite
imaging system makes it easy to capture
images of gel and mem gels and membranes
labeled with no stained reagent and the
eyebrite imaging system offers powerful
integrated software to streamline the
total protein analysis using no stain
reagent labeled gels and membranes
no stain reagent and eyebrite imaging
system offer flexible rapid and accurate
total protein normalization
for your quantitative western blot
results
choosing the right ecl substrate is also
important for quantitative western blot
analysis
chemiluminescent substrates are pushing
the boundary of sensitivity which can be
very important for detecting low
abundant proteins
however for high or medium medium
abundant targets ultra sensitive
substrates may contribute to signal
saturation
making quantitation virtually impossible
on the other end of the spectrum
standard ecl substrates may not be
sensitive enough to detect mid to low
abundant protein targets
quantitative chemiluminescent western
blotting requires an optimal substrate
that provides sensitive linear signals
over a broad range of protein
concentrations
super signal west dura is often the
ideal choice for quantitative western
blot results because it has a long
stable signal
that works across a range of target
concentrations from low to high
abundance
these blot results with super signal
west dura show the importance of
choosing the right chemiluminescent
substrate to ensure you stay in the
linear range of detection for your
protein target of choice
to achieve the most quantitative western
blotting results possible
avoid overloading your sample and avoid
over exposing your images to stay in the
linear range of your protein target
protein normalization is typically more
quantitative than housekeeping proteins
and is the preferred normalization
method
digital imagers are preferred for ease
of use and quantitation because they
have built-in tools like the smart
exposure technology and our eyebrite
imagers
that minimizes overexposure risk to help
ensure you stay in the linear range of
your protein
imagers also provide software for
normalization calculations
and for the best quantity
quantitation select a chemiluminescent
substrate with long signal duration that
will help you stay in the linear range
of detection for your protein of
interest
in this slide i'll briefly summarize a
few key takeaways from all three webinar
sessions that have been presented for
achieving publication quality western
blot data
because more stringent review guidelines
have been developed in recent years it
is necessary to improve reproducibility
and quantitation of western blotting
results
and minimize digital processing of data
the steps we've reviewed throughout this
webinar series include
choosing a trusted antibody source
and validate your target and verify with
positive and negative controls
choose from our many precast gels with
optimum optimized gel chemistries
buffers and membranes to obtain the best
separation and improve band resolution
and background for your protein of
interest
improve detection of low abundance
targets by choosing the right gel
chemistry and using larger format wells
choose a highly sensitive
hemi-luminescent substrate and consider
using signal enhancers when studying
very low abundant proteins
and use a digital
imaging system such as the eyebrite
imaging system with smart exposure to
obscene to obtain sensitive image
detection
increase reproducibility and minimize
time to results through the use of
instrumentation with pre-made
consumables such as the iblot 2 transfer
system and transfer stacks
and improve consistency in hands-on
steps by utilizing instrumentation like
our ibind flex system or bandmate
western blot processing system
to automate the western blot processing
steps and last but but not least
use total protein normalization instead
of housekeeping proteins to obtain
publication quality
quantitative western results
in vitrogen offers an online tool that
can help you optimize your western
blotting experience the in vitrogen blot
builder western black product selection
tool
is designed to help you select the
optimal products for your western body
needs by answering five questions about
your protein of interest
when the five simple questions are
completed you'll receive a list of
recommended products and a personalized
western blotting protocol
you can scan the qr code on the right or
visit the url
thermalfisher.com backslash lot builder
to access the blot builder tool
thank you so much for attending our
webinar today
i believe we will be opening things up
for questions now thank you very much
and thank you kelly for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
joining kelly will be jordan thompson a
product manager
electrophoresis a forces from thermo
fisher scientific he presented the part
one from our webinar series welcome
jordan
so kelly and jordan let's take a look we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience
our first question what is the
difference between dry and semi-dry
transfer
hi thank you i can take that question
so the
dry transfer is a unique
transfer product that that only is
possible with
thermal fissure in vitrogen
select stacks for the power bladder or
the iblot 2 transfer stacks
the
iblot 2 and the select stacks actually
utilize a
unique gel matrix for the
cathode and anode buffer so there's no
extra buffers that are required
and very little
liquid is actually generated during the
transfer step
as opposed to semi-dry transfers that
while they use less liquid than a tank
transfer do still require the use of a
prepared transfer buffer to pre-wet all
of the stack materials
thank you so much and does the iban flex
system require optimization or can i use
it with the same protocol i use for my
traditional western blots
that's a great question so there is some
optimization of your primary and
secondary antibody often required
because the eye binding system utilizes
less liquid volume than traditional
western blotting
protocols
you may recall from the presentation the
ibind flex system uses sequential
lateral flow to perform all the steps
so
there's no timing or
shaking or any of that the blocking
the antibody binding and all the washes
occur automatically and sequentially so
in less than
about three hours you're ready to
process your blot for final detection
and of course you can still continue to
use the same primary and secondary
antibodies and
you know your your detection of choice
thank you so much kelly and again i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next audio audience member says
can i use the band mate system for
overnight incubations
yes of course the the overnight
incubation is entirely possible
um the band mate can be set up in a cold
room for long-term use or overnight
incubations can actually be
performed at room temperature
our r d scientists have shown equivalent
or often better results in westerns
performed at room temperature overnight
versus overnight in a cold room or at 4c
i do know that often people that are
collecting their primary antibodies for
reuse prefer to to have the instrument
set up in their cold room
but it is entirely possible to do those
incubations overnight at room
temperature as well
thank you very much
our next question can dry and semi-dry
transfer be used for transferring high
molecular weight proteins like brca
390 kda
um so yes the the
system um
both the eye by i'm sorry the iblot and
the power bladder system can transfer
high molecular weight proteins
uh it's often better to use
something like a tris acetate gel that
is specifically designed for
high molecular weight proteins and you
may need to
transfer just slightly longer so
maybe up to 10 minutes for an eye blot
for example will help you get more of
that high molecular weight protein out
of the gel and onto the membrane but it
is yes entirely possible to use for high
molecular weight proteins
thank you kelly and we have time for a
few more questions
can no steam be prepared as a master mix
or does it need to be made fresh right
before using
i can take that one
no theme can actually be prepared while
you're doing your separation or your
transfer so it's actually really easy
um you can make a master mix it's stable
for at least an hour
and you can scale up the amount or the
volume of it so that you can prepare
what you need for all the gels or all
the membranes that you're labeling at a
single time
thank you jordan and how does no stain
label proteins in a
sample so no stain actually uses
kelly i'll take this one again
no stain actually uses a fluorogenic
molecule that gets activated so there's
three components to the nostain kit it's
a labeling buffer an activator and the
fluorogenic derivatizer
and so in the presence of the activator
the derivatizer actually reacts with
primary amines and creates a
which is traditionally the lysine side
chains
and it creates a covalently and highly
fluorescent product that can be
visualized on imagers such as the
eyebrite
thank you jordan and did you want to add
anything to that kelly
no i think jordan covered it well thank
you perfect our next question
how to successfully transfer high
molecular weight proteins such as 150
kda
yeah so again um it's highly you know
um
possible to transfer high molecular
weight proteins using
semi-dry or dry rapid transfer often
you'll get better results if you use
a gel like a tris acetate gel but but
even a regular gradient gel
can transfer a high molecular weight
protein quite efficiently using
any of our systems
often you need to
transfer just slightly longer
but you you can get very good results
thank you so much kelly and i want to
thank you for
your responses and your presentation
today did you want to provide any final
comments to our audience before we go
um yes so i would like to thank
everybody again for attending the
webinar series
and for attending today's session and i
hope that you found the information
helpful and
we'll
be able to get better quality western
body results as a result of listening to
the three webinar series thank you so
much for your time and
i think that's it
and we want to thank you again kelly for
your time today and i'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for right underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go i'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand laborats will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone and stay
safe bye